welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down some major Marvel
updates there's been a ton of new
reports dropped over the last couple of
days and as we on doing our podcast this
coming week I thought I'd cover some of
the stories in this oneoff spin-off
video that's because I'm a holiday yeah
going to touch grass finally uh but if
you want to check out our last video
going over all the week's stories then
that's on the channel right now either
way it looks like Kang might be in
trouble as earlier in the week we heard
things involving Jeff lesses firing from
Kang Dynasty according to Joanna
Robinson on the house of all podcast he
was apparently let go because Marvel's
moving away from K this is also brought
up in a variety report but a lot of
that's been debunked so on on the whole
I wouldn't put too much stock in it
however des and Daniel keton has now
been announced as no longer directing
Kang dynasty andless things don't look
good for the big bad time baddy bad now
this couble with the writer being out I
just saw that and instantly thought that
Kang is no longer going to be the focus
of the next f ly kind of left things off
where he could easily brush him to the
side and not have to worry about him
ever coming back obviously Jonathan
Mages is about to start a very public
trial and I think Marvel May realize
that they can't wait for the outcome to
get the ball rolling I've talked about
this a lot and I think that if it was
just a oneof film like the flash then I
I can see why a studio didn't want to
scrap the whole thing K on the other
hand will be popping up in lots of
different projects and also filming for
lots of different things while the
trials going on thus they might just not
want to take the risk and have their
hype around these films getting hit with
that negativity I have to say it's
always innocent until proven guilty a
and the man definitely deserves to have
the right to clear his name I think the
issue though is that there's a big trial
and you also have so many projects that
probably need to feature him and the
main thing that people have said back
when I've talked about this is that
Marvel haven't announced anything and
that the film's still on the Slate going
to be honest Studios in Hollywood they
don't typically tend to come out and
announce they F people especially if
they're going with brand new actors for
example Henry caval and Ben Affleck they
were both said to be out as Superman and
Batman for years but no one at any point
out and out confirmed it it was only
upon them getting brought back that they
made a big song and dance about it and
we realized that they'd actually been
fully out especially in the case with
Henry even then though they weren't
really back either and things can change
all the time too Gina corano is another
example and they just said they weren't
renewing a contract instead of her
actually being fired just look at the
stuff with John kosinski's read and
you'll see why they never just out and
now confirm things have changed if they
don't need to I don't think they'll ever
announce anything until they've got
something else in place and personally
I'd be surprised if we still got Kang
Dynasty boy said that at worst they
should recast but it seems like they're
going to be moving away from that they
obviously have an AA handle Kang the
best and when you have every version of
him that we encounter dying it doesn't
necessarily set him up as a big threat
let's look at how they did Thanos yeah
shows up in a post credit scene another
post credit scene then shows up in
Guardian threatens the main villain then
shows up in Infinity War beats up the
Hulk then beats up everyone and saves
the day you know going into endgame it
was like oh crap whereas on the other
hand it's like oh it's another K just
let him run into a radiation field or
something either way it's never a good
sign when a director and a rider leave
and now they're going to have to do a
complete creative overhaul and
personally I think they might be moving
towards Avengers versus X-men and the
pieces are definitely there for
something like that to happen Deadpool
is right around the corner and yet not
to SPO other stuff but things have
recently been set up that way I think
that would be the smart way to go and
and then you can just take things
directly into Secret Wars also if
they're going to cancel Kang Dynasty
then they need to have something that's
going to get get fans back on board and
I think announcing Avengers versus X-men
you know these two massive franchises
that have dominated comic book movies
for the last 20 years them going
head-to-head that's going to be
something that really gets people
excited and probably will have a lot of
people like okay well well this is
better so I'm glad they've done it also
they could probably swwa k out with doom
which seems to be the thing that people
want the most right now when it comes to
bad guys Doom was the villain in both
versions of Secret Wars and therefore it
just makes sense to have him in place
for the films think that it kind of
sucks cuz Kang was basic K was such a
bad year that he started a multiversal
war that cost trillions of lives and
then was so powerful that the winner of
it ruled over all time now it's just
like ah just keep an eye on a mate it'll
be all right but at least that ending of
logy can explain what's going on with
him now Destin's going to go often work
on wonder and shuni 2 which makes it
seems like they're further going into
these characters films instead of a big
teamup Wonderman is actually a Disney
plush show and blood bloody Wonder Man e
gender swapping wonder you gone bloody
walk have you but yeah it's still weird
that we still haven't had an Avengers
film yet and our next one at the
earliest is 2026 that means it's going
to be seven years since the last one and
I think they might even rush out a Young
Avengers film another reason I feel like
des and leaving is bad is because the
pay on an Avengers movie would be
massive and for him to turn that down
and work on the other two would probably
make less sense working on an Avengers
movie is a bigger career move to me than
both Wonderman and shangi put together
but let me know below if you agree with
that or not either way things aren't
looking good for Jonathan majes which is
a shame cu the guy is a really talented
actor M went from having the two number
one films in the world with Creed 3 and
Quantum Mania with a whole MCU phase
built up around him uh I don't even know
what's happening with that but it
doesn't look good and yet it it is kind
of crazy to see how how things have
changed that quickly when you think
about it you know Quantum Mania
underperformed critically and
commercially secret Invasion that had
the worst finale ever like 8% on run Tom
models the Marvels has had the lowest
MCU opening weekend and yeah things they
just need to reshuffle and this whole
Kang news on top of that with Jonathan
majes just just things need to change
either way you like you like Marvel
don't you you like Loki yeah well guess
what we've got a Loki inspired t-shirt
right Bel the video that you can pick up
now it all goes towards helping videos
like this get made and huge thank you to
everyone that bought one if you don't
want to buy one but still want to help
out a like comment share subscribe sell
your soul to us is much appreciated too
now another stories we've had a ton of
read Richard castings over the last year
there's been krinski obviously people
people like pen Bley Dev Patel Adam
Driver Matt Smith I think was one Kevin
spoilers Jake jelen Hall and so on and
so forth still though no one signed on
and from what heard this was largely
down to the scripts and Strikes from
what I was told Vanessa Kirby was a lock
from the star and the movie is's going
to be built up around Su Richards they
wanted to have people auditioning screen
test against her but due to the strike
they couldn't do this un thus they've
been holding off now that takes us to
the day where Pedro Pascal is reportedly
very close to signing things I know
there's a lot of people confirming that
this is the case but as of making this
video there's not anywhere that I can
find that he's definitely in the film
the rumor came from Daniel rpk and even
he had to come out and say look he
hasn't signed it yet however if you're
watching this video in the future when
he has then I just want to let you know
that we broke the news first he has
signed and his whole story is confirmed
confirmed confirmed unfortunately though
because of how a Twitter is right now
anyone can buy a tick and look like a
proper news Outlet so careful when
looking at stuff on Twitter hey don't
follow that only fans girl mate your
mates are going to see now Pedro is an
interesting choice but he's not someone
I would have assumed would have been in
the running pered however he's so hot
right now and it actually makes sense
with the roles that he's played in the
past read is re is a bit of an ass in
the comics at point and Pedro can
definitely pull that off however he can
be likable as well but the big question
is will the man shave the mustache or
just keep it in place now due to his age
in the fact he plays every dad on the
planet including yours I also think this
could hint out what direction that
they're taking things reading Su our
parents in the comics and the one we
encounted in the 838 was also one as
well thus I think this would allow both
Franklin and Valeria to come in as both
both are big characters in the comics I
really hope they're basing things around
the Fantastic for Jonathan Hickman run
as that could then lead perfectly into
Secret Wars like I said I still think
Secret Wars is coming but we just have
to get through the movie before that
first who knows what's happening but
there's been a lot of shakeups at Marvel
and I think that there's going to be a
lot more the Marvel's is really really
going to struggle to break even and
after the lowest opening for an MC movie
the studio is probably panicking they
just seem to be releasing as much as
possible at the moment and getting
things out the way before they change
course personally I've always thought
they should just push everything back
that isn't connected to Secret Wars and
just basically have every project
building up to that stuff like Agatha
that can probably come out after the
film and even blade can I as well I
imagine that's going through development
hell at the moment and I think all these
negative stories just look bad on the
studio feels like we're back with these
in 2017 where they were just announcing
loads of stuff and then either it
doesn't get made or it does get made
made in its mid so I'm hoping that the
Marvels has been a big wakeup call for
them and they're finally realizing what
needs to be done I know people are
saying the strikes are white doing bad
but I think that film had more than
enough marketing just for that movie we
had three Disney Plus shows several
trailers and it's sequel to a billion
dollar movie that's attached to the MCU
so yeah I don't know how how much more
marketing or an appearance on Jimmy
Kimmel I don't think that would have
broke the bank even just having the
Marvel name attached to your film is
such a big push and that's why Sony was
so desperate to be connected to the MCU
so my hope is that they're not blaming
that and actually being self-aware
enough to realize things need to change
and fast anyway I'd of course love to
hear your thoughts on the story and
again no across the spoiler verse coming
next week if you want to check out our
last video though that's linked below
and huge thank you to everyone who's now
a regular listener at our highest views
3 weeks in a row now so we massively
appreciate everyone who's watching
please drop a like on this video and
thank you again for all your support now
if you want to watch something else that
video is on screen right now or we've
got a breakdown of The Madam web trailer
which I actually quite enjoyed I like a
bit of a Terminator Spider-Man thing but
a lot of people don't seem to um yes I'm
chilling and we also got the ly finale
on screen right now so yeah thanks a lot
for sitting through this I hope you have
a good week mate as well and I'm off to
enjoy my holiday you take care
peace